ich denke nicht dass wir da jetzt
verstärkt mit diesen mit diesen Flügen
der russischen luftschaltkräfte zu
rechnen haben weil diese diese Übung ist
in keinster Weise auf Eskalation oder
Aggression ausgelegt wir machen
keinerlei Flüge in Richtung Kaliningrad
aber wir haben nach wie vor unsere
sogenannten nato-alarmorten so nennen
wir das also wir haben an mehreren
Standorten in Deutschland jeweils zwei
Kampfflugzeuge voll bewaffnet auf 15
Minuten Bereitschaft stehen dass wenn
sowas vorkommen würde dann würden wir
das auch so machen wie wir das sonst im
NATO Rahmen auch wie wir sagen
abarbeiten
ich habe ja gerade schon kurz mit meinem
zdf-kollegen Florian neuhahn in Brüssel
gesprochen der sieht in dieser Übung
schon eine Art Signalwirkung eine Art
Abschreckung der NATO die da Richtung
Russland geht würden sie den zustimmen
naja zuvor dass das erste Signal und ich
habe diese Übung ja 2018 erstmalig
vorgeschlagen in Amerika da war
natürlich das was uns alle schockiert
hat die Annexion der Krim
völkerrechtswidrig sagte das ist nicht
akzeptabel dass wir schon klar machen
müssen
Landes- und bündnisverteilung wir können
das und zum anderen das nato-theoretum
ist die rote Linie so das wesentlich
Signal geht an uns selbst auch an unsere
Bevölkerung dass wir in der Lage sind zu
regieren und dass wir das können ähm und
ich würde jetzt nicht speziell das
Signal gegen Russland senden aber es ist
auch eins klar mit dem Blick auf
Russland es ist absolut inakzeptabel
dass man denkt in diesen jetzigen Zeiten
in Europa zu meinen Grenze mit Gewalt zu
verschieben
lassen Sie uns noch mal einen Blick auf
die deutsche Luftwaffe sprechen die sie
ja einen Blick darauf werfen wie sie ja
verantworten wir haben das mit einem
Experten von der Stiftung Wissenschaft
und Politik gesprochen haben Arnold der
dazu folgendes gesagt hat
diese Übung wurde bei längeren Zeitraum
geplant und demnach wurden auch die
Verfügbarkeiten von Luftfahrzeugen genau
auf diese Übung abgestimmt so dass man
mit einem hohen technischen Klarstand in
diese Übung starten kann grundsätzlich
können wir sagen dass in den letzten
Jahren einige Fortschritte erzielt
worden die klarsteine gerade im Bereich
unserer Eurofighter Flotte ist erheblich
gestiegen dort gab es Umstellung seitens
der Bundeswehr Anpassungen seitens der
Industrie und dadurch konnten dann mehr
Flieger einsatzbereit sein als wir die
Jahre davor erlebt haben natürlich bei
den älteren Maschinen bei dem Tornado
oder vielleicht auch bei unseren
Hubschraubern haben wir gesehen dass
natürlich aufgrund des Alters hier und
da mehrere Ausfälle immer wieder
hinzunehmen sind
im Prinzip sagt ist ja dass ich jetzt
für diese Übung sehr gut vorbereitet
wurde das auch in den letzten Jahren
diese flotten sich verbessert haben aber
das natürlich jetzt explizit auch auf
die Übung
hingearbeitet wurde was würden Sie denn
sagen ist die deutsche Luftwaffe aktuell
immer einsatzbereit oder liegt das jetzt
auch daran dass ich speziell für diese
Übung vorbereitet wurde
also was Herne da natürlich für einen
ein Bild skizziert ist genau dieses
differenzierte Bild das wir in Teilen
über hochmoderne Systeme verfügen die
auch mit einer hohen Einsatzbereitschaft
versehen sind Eurofighter als ich die
Luftwaffe 2018 übernommen habe hatten
wir gerade mal etwas über 30%
Einsatzbereitschaft wir liegen heute bei
80% und das liegen wir nicht nur weil
wir diese Übung fliegen sondern weil wir
das grundsätzlich so gestärkt haben aber
unsere älteren Waffensysteme jetzt z.B
das Waffensystem Tornado was wir jetzt
ja durch die R35 ersetzen und noch
weitere Eurofighter oder z.B
Hubschrauber durch den neuen
Hubschrauber den sogenannten schweren
Transporthubschrauber also man muss es
wirklich der franzisiert sehen in Teilen
haben wir schon sehr modernes Gerät und
teilen verfügen wir noch über Technik
veraltetes Gerät was natürlich jetzt in
den nächsten Jahren modernisiert werden
muss dafür lässt ist ja letztlich auch
der Sondervermögen da
zum Sondervermögen kommen wir gleich
noch mal ich würde gerne noch mal über
das Personal sprechen das Gerät ist ja
die eine Herausforderung die sie auch
schon angesprochen haben das hat sich in
ihrer Laufbahn quasi schon stark
entwickelt wie sieht es denn aus mit der
Personalbesetzung gibt es da im
Ernstfall eigentlich genug Leute
also wir in der Luftwaffe wir haben
schon auf unserem Position top
ausgebildet es ist ein gutes Personal
und ich bin ja heute hier in Wunstorf zu
Übungsbeginn da wo wir auch unseren
logistische Drehscheibe haben und ich
habe heute schon mit vielen Amerikaner
gesprochen die war aber auch letzte
Frage Freitag in Norddeutschland in
Schleswig und den hohen und wenn ich mit
anderen Nationen spreche auch die
Nationen die in unserer Planung
beteiligt sind dann höre ich von den
Leuten was ihr für tolles Personal habt
ihr seid top ausgebildet also das ist
auch eigentlich ein starkes Statement
was wir auch mal nach vorne schieben
müssen dass wir eben gut ausgebildet ist
Personal haben dass unsere Leute
wirklich was können dass wir so eine
Übung auch organisieren können und wir
werden es in den nächsten Jahren das
wird aber das das wenn sie
gesellschaftlich schauen ist das ohne
hin die größte Herausforderung für alle
ausreichend Fachkräfte zu haben das
trifft uns natürlich genauso und da
werden wir die nächsten Jahre natürlich
immer hart dran arbeiten müssen
ja und jetzt noch Stichwort sondern
Vermögen das hat ja letztes Jahr in der
politischen Debatte so ein bisschen die
von Scholz besprochene zeitenwände
eingeleitet wie kommen Sie denn bei der
Luftwaffe aktuell klar mit diesem
Sondervermögen reicht das im großen
Teile des Bedarf zu decken oder fehlt
das dann noch was
also das Sondervermögen das ist viel
Geld und es ist auch gut wir müssen uns
auch sinnvoll nutzen und wir müssen
schnell nutzen aber man muss es als ich
sag's immer man muss das eine
Anschubfinanzierung sehen und es muss
natürlich die nächsten Jahre
entsprechend der jährliche Titel für die
Bundeswehr entsprechend mit wachsen so
dass wir dann auch über die Mittel haben
einmal das moderne Gerät was wir jetzt
über Sondervermögen beschaffen dann auch
betreiben zu können und z.B im Bereich
der der Bewaffnung der Munition haben
wir in Teilen auch in erhebliches
Defizit da müssen wir mehr davon kaufen
also quantitative Frage und da ist
natürlich nicht nur ausreichend das
Sondervermögen
danke bis hierhin wir haben noch
die die jetzt live eingetrudelt sind die
würde ich auch noch mal an Sie richten
und zwar fragt Michaela Neubert auf
YouTube wird es vorkommen dass bei der
Übung auch über nicht geplante Gebiete
in Deutschland geflogen wird
noch mal die Frage das was für Gebiete
in Deutschland überflogen wird ob es
vorkommen wird das während der Übung
auch über aktuell nicht geplante Gebiete
geflogen wird also wird es da
Überraschungen geben nein
das ist eine klare Überraschung geben
okay dann haben sie noch eine Frage ich
habe noch eine Frage Entschuldigung wir
haben glaube ich eine leichte
Verzögerung hier fragt noch jemand auf
facebook weiß man den wie die Aktion von
Russland aktuell propagandistisch
begleitet wird es wird ja Putin enorm
viele Möglichkeiten diese Übungen
propagandistisch für sich
auszuschlachten
also ich denke mal aus aus deren Sicht
sehe ich jetzt nicht unbedingt das
Bestreben dass oder auch nicht unbedingt
die Möglichkeit dass das protagonistisch
auszuschlagen weil wir natürlich zeigen
zusammen wie schnell und wie stark wir
reagieren können und ich ähm wir werden
das natürlich beobachten aber bis jetzt
ist da noch nicht zu erkennen
dann haben wir noch mal eine sehr
konkrete Frage zum Schluss auf Youtube
da fragt jemand wie viele einsatzfähige
deutsche Kampfflugzeuge haben wir
überhaupt
ähm also für verfügen die genaue Zeit
gar nicht so in die nennen aber für
verwöhnen über mehr als ausreichend also
wenn wir mal schauen bei den 250
Flugzeugen die bei dieser Übung
teilnehmen sind ungefähr 190
Kampfflugzeuge dabei die Amerikaner
Stellen mit mit ca 80 und wir stellen
dann mit ca 70 Flugzeuge dass die
zweitgrößte Kontingent personell sogar
mehr als die Hälfte also das zeigt schon
dass wir über eine hohe
Einsatzbereitschaft verfügen
Ingo Gerhardt der Inspektor der
Luftwaffe vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns
waren